[Musique]
service qui s'appelle s'abandonner à
vivre de sylvain tesson
non je ne suis pas mais par contre si tu
peux si tu peux me suivre ben moi mon
instagram c'est magnifique
il ya plein de choses qui m'énervent
mais en ce moment il fait très froid et
je vois des familles dehors dans métro
dans la rue et l impression qu il y en a
de plus en plus et c'est pas une
impression c'est vrai ça ça m'énerve
ben ouais bon peut-être faire de verre
en terrasse
pouvoir
bagarre ce couple le scoop c'est que à
la fin de ma tournée d'été j'arrête
temporairement la musique pour une
période indéterminée
mais je te conseille le mien ça ne
devant qu'à la voir on a mis cinq ans
pour le faire et on en est très fier